we're learning more tonight about just
how involved then President Obama may
have been in the months leading up to
the 2016 presidential election as the
FBI's Russia probe expanded chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge shows us the evidence tonight
those tax totally candid unvarnished
just raised an awful lot of questions
Republican Senator Ron Johnson
Government Oversight Committee released
an interim report including the FBI text
messages that draw new connections to
President Obama in September 2016
two months after the FBI closed the
Clinton email case and two months into
the bureau's Russia probe then FBI agent
Peter struck text FBI lawyer Lisa page
using Bureau shorthand talking points
for director Comey page replies yes
because POTUS wants to know everything
we are doing it's not clear whether
Strunk and Paige are referring to either
investigation or something else in an
interview on Fox News Sunday at the
height of the FBI's criminal email case
President Obama insisted he was not in
the loop I do not talk to the Attorney
General about pending investigations I
do not talk to FBI directors about
pending investigations they we have a
strict line and always have maintained
it in then FBI director Comey's July
2016 recommendation against criminal
charges the early draft said emails
between Clinton and President Obama had
probably been compromised by hackers a
week before Comey publicly closed the
case Strunk in others including his boss
bill pre staff head of FBI
counterintelligence watered down the
language Strunk writes hope so just left
bill pre-snap he changed president to
another senior government official the
reference was then removed altogether
after the election both patients from
texted about being depressed in
mid-november Paige writes I bottled the
president's men figure I needed to brush
up on Watergate the next day Paige
follows up God being here makes me angry
lots of highfalutin national security
top meanwhile we have our task ahead of
us
Senate investigators question whether
there's a connection to this August text
where the two discuss an insurance
policy while Strunk and Paige are no
longer assigned a special counsel Robert
Muller's
probe the White House press secretary
said their reservations remain this
further shows that there is reason for
all of us have great cause for concern
in this process in her April 2016 FBI
interview Clinton aide Huma Abedin was
shown an email between President Obama
who used a pseudonym and Secretary
Clinton that was exchanged during a trip
to Russia Albany and send the email had
to be classified and then asked FBI
agents for her own copy Shin this story
is far from over I have a few paths for
sure keep diggin thank you